2026년 5월 19일 화요일 미국 증시 유약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 하락 마감했습니다.
S&P 오브지수는 0.67% 하락하며 3거래 연속 약세를 이어갔습니다.
미국과 이란 간의 종전협정 지원으로 유가와 인플레이션 우려가 다시 고개를 든 가운데
국채금리마저 치솟으면서 시장 전반에 부담이 가중되었습니다.
최근 국채금리가 수년 만에 최고치로 치솟으며 시장의 새로운 걸림돌이 되고 있습니다.
화요일 미국 30년무 국채금리는 장중 한때 5.19%를 돌파하며 약 19년 만에 최고치를 기록했습니다.
주택담보대출, 자동차대출, 신용카드금리의 핵심 기준이 되는 10년무 국채금리 역시 한때 4.687%까지 솟으며
2025년 1월 이후 가장 높은 수준에 도달했습니다.
이 같은 금리 상승은 장기적인 경제 성장을 둔화시키는 동시에
그동안 일부 반도체주에서 나타난 높은 밸류이션에도 부담하지만
이런 부담 속에서 그동안 AI 열풍에 휘입어 가파른 상승세를 이어가던 주요 반도체주들은
최근 변동세가 크게 확대되고 있습니다.
필라델피아 반도체 지수는 화요일 장중 한때 3.6%까지 급락한 뒤
결국 낙폭을 대부분 회복하며 보악건으로 장을 마쳤습니다.
이제 시장의 모든 관심은 수요일 장마감후 발표돼 MBDA 실적에 집중되고 있습니다.
이번 실적 발표는 그동안 이어온 가파른 상승세를 뒷받칠 만큼
수요가 강력한지를 증명하는 시험대가 될 것이며
결과에 따라 반도체 섹터뿐만 아니라 증시 전체의 방향성이 결정될 것으로 예상됩니다.
지정학적 측면에서는 트럼프 대통령이 전쟁 종신을 위한 협상을 압박하는 과정에서
며칠 내로 이란에 대한 공세를 재개할 수 있다고 위협했습니다.
반면 벤스 부통령은 미국과 이란 회담에서 상당한 진전을 이뤘으며
양측 모두 군사 작전이 재개되는 것을 원치 않는다고 밝히며 온도차를 보였습니다.
프라임 캡탈 파이낸셜의 웰 맥커프는
지금 채권 자경단이 움직이고 있다.
케빈 워시 차기 연준 의장의 취임을 앞두고
투자들이 연준의 인플레이션 대응에 뒤처져 있다는 메시지를 보내고 있는 것일 수 있다.
밀러 타박의 맷 말리는
국채 금리 상승은 현재의 높은 주시장 밸류에이션에 부담을 줄 수 있는 요인이다.
로젠 블랏의 마이클 제임스는
실효성 있는 휴연이 이뤄질 것이라고 믿을 만한 긍정적인 단서가 전혀 없다.
이 부분에서
진전이 없는 한 유가와 국채 금리는 계속 높은 수준에 머물 것이고
시장의 불안감도 점점 더 커질 것이다.
라고 전하였습니다.
2026년 5월 20일 수요일 주요 일정 살펴보겠습니다.
경제 지표는
22시 15분 연준 바이사
23시 30분 미국 EIA 원유 재고
02시 미국 20년물 국채 경매
03시 연준 FOMC 의사록이
예정되어 있습니다.
지금까지 뉴스 스토리였습니다.